simplify three a to the fifth over nine
a squared times a to the fourth over a
to the third so before we even worry
about the a's we can actually simplify
the three and the nine they're both
divisible by three so let's divide the
denominator and the or divide the
numerator and the denominator here by
three so if we divide the numerator by
three the three becomes a one if we
divide the denominator by three the nine
becomes a three so this reduces to or
simplifies to one a to the fifth times a
to the fourth
over or maybe i should say a to the
fifth over three a squared times a to
the fourth over a to the third now this
if we just multiply the two expressions
this would be equal to one a to the
fifth times a to the 4th in the
numerator and we don't have to worry
about the 1. it doesn't change the value
so it's a to the 5th
times a to the 4th in the numerator and
then we have 3
8 let me write the 3 like this and then
we have 3 times a squared times
a to the third in the denominator and
now there's multiple ways that we can
simplify this from here one sometimes
it's called the quotient rule and that's
just the idea it's just the idea that if
you have a to the x
over
a to the y that this is going to be
equal to a to the x minus y and just to
understand why that why that works let's
think about a to the fifth over a
squared so a to the fifth is literally
a to the fifth
is literally a times a times a times a
times a
that right there is a to the fifth
and we have that over a squared
and i'm just thinking about the a
squared right over here so we have that
over a squared which is literally just a
times a
that is a squared now we can clearly
both the numerator and the denominator
are both divisible by a times a we can
divide them both by a times a so we can
get rid of if we divide the numerator by
a twice by a times a so let's get rid of
an a times a and if we divide the
denominator by a times a we just get a
1. so what are we just left with we are
left with
just a times a times a over 1
which is just a times a times a a times
a times a but what is this this is a to
the third power or a
to the 5 minus 3 or sorry a to the 5
minus 2 power we had 5 we were able to
cancel out 2. that gave us 3. so we can
do the same thing over here we can apply
the quotient rule and i'll do two ways
of actually doing this so let's apply
the quotient rule with the a to the
fifth and the a squared and also so
let's let me do it this way
so let's apply with these two guys and
then let's apply it and then let's apply
it with these two guys and of course we
have the one-third we have the one-third
out front so this can be reduced to
one-third
times if we apply the quotient rule with
a to the fifth over eight squared we
just applied it over here that becomes a
to the third power and if we apply it
over here with the a to the fourth
over a to the third that'll give us a
that'll give us let me do that same blue
color that'll give us a
that's not the same blue color
there we go this will give us a to the 4
minus 3 power
or a to the first power and of course we
can simplify this as
a to the third
times a well actually let me just do it
over here over before we even rewrite it
we know that a to the third times a to
the first is going to be a to the three
plus one power we have the same base we
can add the exponents we're multiplying
a times itself three times and then one
more time so that'll be a to the fourth
power
so this right over here becomes a to the
fourth power a to the three plus one
power and then we have to multiply that
by one third so our answer could be
one-third a to the fourth or we could
equivalently equally write it a to the
fourth
over three now the other way to do this
problem would have been to apply the
product or to add the exponents in the
numerator and then add the exponents in
the denominator so let's do it that way
first so if we add the exponents to the
numerator first we don't apply the
quotient rule first we apply it second
we get in the numerator a to the fifth
times a to the fourth would be a to the
ninth power
five plus 4 and then in the denominator
in the denominator we have a squared
times a to the third add the exponents
because we're taking the product with
the same base so it'll be a to the fifth
power and of course we still have this 3
down here we have a 1 3 or we could just
write a 3 over here now we could apply
now we could apply the quotient property
of exponents we could say look we have a
to the ninth over a to the fifth a to
the ninth over a to the fifth is equal
to a to the nine minus five power or
it's equal to
a to the fourth power and of course we
still have the divided by three
we still have the divided by three
either way
either way we got the same answer